a sustainable world has already been
invented it's right outside how is this
being done and how can we mimic it we
think of co2 as the poison of our era as
we have such excess of it but in the
natural world co2 is a building block
anything green that you see from algae
to the trees is composed of carbon
dioxide and anything hard in the ocean
like coral reefs or shells they're made
from dissolved co2 concrete which is our
largest building material releases a ton
of co2 for every ton of concrete six to
eight percent of all co2 emissions are
concrete with coral reefs it's the
opposite co2 is sequestered in the reef
so there's a company called colera that
was started by a coral researcher and he
took the recipe from the coral reef and
now he takes co2 from smokestacks
bubbles it through seawater to get the
minerals and out precipitates the raw
material for cement which is then used
to make concrete if we began to think of
co2 as feedstock for our stuff it might
be a way to begin to use some of this
excess co2 to learn more about
biomimicry subscribe to the wired
Channel